bonjour les petits-enfants nous
attendons ulysse est grosse
ouais ils reviennent ce soir d'un très
long voyage et ils nous ont envoyé un
télégramme ret arrive on s'en fout de ce
soir impatient de vous revoir encore et
un mille baisers stop lycée votre gros
noyau post up
non tu pas aussi nous avons mis toute la
maison bien au nord et nous avons été
très sage jamais oui mais oui les
enfants
nous revoilà re lui le oui nous vous
avions promis que nous reviendrions
bientôt et vous le voyez nous sommes
revenus ben oui oui vous nous manquiez
beaucoup vous savez
avez vous été sage pendant notre absence
a pas tous les jours mais vous êtes
allez vous coucher très sagement tous
les soirs je le sais gentili c'est très
bien ça petit louis et mirabel gros
source on descend vite les voir oui
patron
j'y cours ou au top au bonjour bonjour
mr petizon aubin sont internet tous les
jours 10 m et vous avez reçu d'autres
télégrammes au moins 15 les voilà à on
était très sages pendant votre absence
et tous les soirs tous les soirs on
allait se coucher fit mais je le sais
c'est bien à cause de ça qu'on est
revenu à 49 regarde on a beaucoup
travaillé
moi j'ai fait plein bâton tu vois et moi
je fais à théo des a et des oeufs
soyez sans crainte pas trop je n'ai pas
oublié elle est bien puisque vous avez
été si sage
ouah j'ai pensé à vous les voilà et
joujou chinois pour petit louis beaux
drago et pour me rappelle une mignonne
petite poupée chinoise bien sûr oui
[Musique]
et alors vous êtes allé chez les chinois
et si loin c'est l'ouest chinois
c'est loin très loin mais demain nous
vous raconterons tout notre voyage et
maintenant aller vite au dodo l'a pas
permis
[Musique]
c'est bien vrai ces jurés les enfants
alors dormez-vous vite
j'éteins la lumière
parfois vatry revoir les listes mirabel
monument qui lui
avec ichimei venir gros dragon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans nuiton et petit ami sommes vraiment
très heureux d'être venu vous voir
car vous avez
vous nous avez beaucoup manqué
mais nous avons aussi été très heureux
de recevoir toutes les belles lettres
que vous avez écrite en fait très
plaisir et nous vous en remercions mille
fois au score alors en route nounours en
route à demain les enfants
bonne nuit dans mes vite et faites de
beaux rêves
[Musique]
e